hello everyone welcome to omix logic B
informatics community in this video we
will be providing you with stepbystep
guidelines on how to access the
complimentary resources as a part of our
recent webinar on omix logic multiomic
research internship program in case you
missed or wish to rewatch the webinar
the recording can be access on our
program website the link to same will be
shared with the registered participants
over and email in this webinar we
introduce the participants to a research
program where students and researchers
can advance their studies or research by
training in various omix data analysis
techniques across different
specialization track to help you get a
glimpse of this program we have designed
an Innovative short multiomic workshop
on sell line cancer case study that you
can review and
learn as a part of the complimentary
resource coures to this Workshop you
will get access to our meticulously
curated online courses on introduction
to bioinformatics bytes and molecules as
well as a specialized coursework on
patient derived xenograph models these
online courses include short video
tutorials visuals link to data sets
Associated Publications and more
additionally participants will also be
getting demo access to our Cloud
research infrastructure
where they can practice several of the
data analysis techniques that are
covered in the cours
workk now here is a stepbystep guideline
on how you can get enrolled in the
program the first step is the
registration process this has commenced
as of December 26 and will end on
January 2nd so during this duration the
registered participants are required to
sign up on the women's logic Le platform
and complete your profile then you're
requested to reach out to us with your
learn you ID in the registration form
that will be shared with you in the
Second Step upon successful registration
the participants will gain access to the
program courses and demo access to the
cloud research
infrastructure the program will end as
of January 9th so the participants are
requested to complete their training
till that date finally the feedback and
certification upon completion of the
program the participants will submit a
learning progress feedback and earn a
certificate recognizing their
participation now I'll show you how you
can sign up on the omix logic learn
portal first visit learn. omix logic.com
and click on the login option that you
see here if you already have an existing
account on the portal simply enter your
existing email ID and password and click
on sign in if you are registering for
the first time click on create an
account option that you see here enter
your name email ID password and few
other details and then you can create an
account or you can also sign up using
any of your existing social media
handles such as Google Facebook GitHub
account or Twitter since I already have
an existing account I have signed up
using my email ID and password and the
very first interface that you see is the
courses page now to set up your Prof
file on the top blue bar that you see
here you will see welcome back with your
email ID click on that and it will
redirect you to the profile
settings once you're in your profile
settings there are few features that you
need to update to do the same simply
head over to the profile button that you
see here and enter a few details make
sure that your name is in proper
capitalization add a profile image a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your education background and
research interest and a link to your
social media handles this could be your
LinkedIn account Facebook account or ID
or other social media handles once this
is completed click on update and this
will automatically get updated to enroll
in the program you are required to
submit your learn U ID to do the same
simply go to your profile settings and
in the profile settings you will see the
link to your profile simply copy this
and add it in the Google form that has
been shared with you now in your profile
you will also see several other sections
such as activity courses projects
programs and certificates in the
activity section you'll be able to see
the learning progress that you have been
making under the course section it'll
display the course progress that you
have been making as well as the various
example projects that you might be going
through under the programs tab it will
display the workshop access that you
will be receiving once your profile has
been
completed and under the certificates tab
it will help you download the various
certificates that you get as a part of
the cours work as well as for the
program at the end of the workshop if
you're interested to work on an
independent research project you can
consider enrolling for the omix logic
multix research program under the
guidance of a mentor the details of this
will be
available on our program website and the
link will be available in the email that
has been shared thank you and we look
forward to seeing your
participation